efforts are underway tonight to save
hundreds of roosters
from a cockfighting ring the violent
criminal act involves fitting the bird's
legs with blades so they fight
and ultimately kill each other sasha
loftus joining us live near lamb in lake
mead with more on the efforts to crack
down
on this kind of absolute cruelty sasha
brian people we spoke with in this area
say sadly they're not surprised
that this happened now the animal
advocate i spoke with tonight
says that cockfighting is still
prevalent here in nevada and really all
across the world
that's why he and his team are working
to end this animal cruelty
a huge case of animal cruelty sparks
reaction in the northeast
valley i don't think anybody should be
doing that for any reason
metro police rescued over 300 roosters
from this house on friday
and arrested a man believed to be a
major player in a cockfighting ring
what is likely occurring here is this is
an individual that raises and sells to
other people
and then he oftentimes is probably
involved in the fighting himself
these razors which attach to the bird's
legs so they can fight each other to the
death
were also found on the property when you
dismantle these [ __ ] fighting rings
you're really dismantling dismantling a
larger criminal
enterprise president of animal wellness
action wayne paselli
calls nevada a [ __ ] fighting hot spot
due to location
and connection to other countries a lot
of these birds
are fought locally others are sold to
mexico to the philippines
and all over the world that's why his
team is pushing legislation for a
federal crime unit
to help local law enforcement crack down
it's good that these people
get punishments for it and those we
spoke with are
all for this kind of extra enforcement
to protect all animals from these savage
situations animals deserve just as much
like
kind and respect as we do
back out here live the man arrested here
at this home is facing multiple
drug charges tonight police say those
felony animal cruelty charges
should be added on at a later time
including animal torture
and fighting charges for that brian
before you go what will happen to the
birds who were removed from the property
today
brian police say that they all went to
the animal foundation
they are doing the best they can to
rehabilitate these birds so they can
re-home them but unfortunately
the animal advocate i spoke with said
that a lot of birds in these situations
do end up having to be euthanized
reporting live here in the northeast
valley sasha loftis 8 news now